la rabia se respira en el sur de Perú
luego de que el miércoles las
manifestaciones en contra del gobierno
de Dina boluarte dejaran un muerto y
decenas de heridos en las protestas que
parecen no Cesar y que han sido
duramente reprimidas por la policía del
país
el descontento se extendió por otras
partes del territorio peruano en más de
41 provincias los manifestantes
bloquearon las calles y carreteras
unos actos de protesta que se dan
mientras las denuncias sobre violación a
los Derechos Humanos no paran de llegar
el miércoles llegó una delegación de la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos para investigar la situación del
país
en paralelo Perú se vistió de luto las
familias de juliaca despidieron a 17 de
sus seres queridos que perdieron la vida
en las protestas culpan al gobierno de
boluarte las banderas negras de nuestro
pueblo significan de el gobierno este
usurpador ha asesinado al pueblo y
exigen justicia y empezaron a disparar a
quemarropa a quien
sea que toque ha muerto no era un
protestante él estaba pasando se ha
asomado y es vecino él se ha asomado
nada más Y de frente le ha caído el el
arma de fuego le ha caído acá
los ánimos no parecen menar en Perú el
país latinoamericano se enfrenta a su
peor brote de violencia en 20 años
uno que se dio después de la destitución
del expresidente Pedro Castillo el mes
pasado quienes suponen el ocurrido con
el exmandatario exigen también la salida
de la presidenta Dina boluarte